it is day one of american craft beer
week and rocky is live with the nevada
craft brewers association to find out
what's ruined locally hey rocky how's it
going
hey jc jc did you see my shot earlier in
the show i just want to know i just want
to let you guys all know that i secretly
called bank in my head okay so don't
judge me all right so let's talk to tim
he is the owner of tenea creek brewery
here in vegas of course and as you said
the nevada craft brewery association
these are the stars of that talk about
the association and what it does for the
community of breweries here well the
association is put together by nevada
breweries and we're basically a group of
small small businesses here local in the
state of nevada so what you're doing is
you're supporting local and when you
hear that nevada craft brewers
association
we're the small breweries we're the
small businesses and
you know if you want to support local
then please come support us that is a
great way to support local and of course
i also want to point out that the cool
artwork on these cans that's also local
artists right exactly exactly
most if not all of them are nevada
artists very cool very cool all right
let's get to tasting okay i can't be
here without tasting some beer so what
should i try
well you've got to try the one that you
made the shot with
mike exactly my good luck beer
um
it's very light it's very light very
light this one is our pilsner it is it
is a pilsner it's a worldwide style
we've done our best to try to emulate
that
light in color does not necessarily mean
light and alcohol
okay so being that this is light this
might be our light beer but it's also
light and alcohol it's five point
two percent okay but you try to try this
one
what happens now so that's dark in color
but not necessarily dark or
heavy in alcohol wow but this one's
stronger though so that's interesting
it's interesting it's got a stronger
flavor kind of a burnt flavor guinness
is a perfect example
that is lighter in alcohol than the one
the first one you tried there you go and
all of that is brewed right here in this
brewery here so tell everybody about
your specials all week and then just
invite them down so this being american
craft brewers week we've got specials
every day
we've got four dollar pints on specific
beers each
each
each day is a different beer and it'll
be four dollars a pint come on down you
try a different beer each day and i have
to say i i recommend this one what do
they got what do they have to order when
they order this one
secret password hauling oats
okay there we go i'll send it back to
you guys finish it this is good finish
it drink drink drink
drink no i'm sending it back to you
james
thank you rocky there's more las vegas
now coming up after the break